perhaps even more than the increase in
interest rates which of course is
significant it's a half a percentage
point increase that's the largest since
the bank became independent in the late
90s it's the largest in more than 30
years is it's going to whack 650 quid
onto the annual repayments of anyone
with a average size tracker mortgage
that's pretty significant but perhaps
even more than that action by the bank
is the context you've just mentioned
there this is a bleak bleak forecast for
business for consumers for households
and for anyone who wants to lead the
country in the coming months they're
talking about five quarters of recession
beginning in the fourth quarter of this
year so that's throughout 2023 the
economy will be in recession and even
while it comes out in the first quarter
of 2024 the net effect of that which
will be the bank believes the economy
will shrink both in 2023 and in 2024 so
that's two annual uh consecutive years
of contraction we haven't seen that
since the 1960s and the scary number
in this is the inflation figure you've
just mentioned the bank believes that
inflation will peak at 13.3
this october that is broadly in line
with the introduction of the new energy
price cap that offgen will give us at
the end of august it will be introduced
in october the bank says it believes
that figure will be three and a half
thousand pounds
per household that's an average typical
usage figure it's not the highest it
could be it could be even higher than
that but that's three times larger than
the figure a year ago there is a glimmer
of light around the price cap off gem is
going to review the figure again it said
this morning in january and there are
independent forecasts that say the
figure will be even higher than three
and a half thousand pounds but the bank
does believe that won't necessarily see
the inflationary curve continue to
increase it believes that falling
commodity prices and some other cost
pressures may already have peaked so
that will knock the froth off the top of
inflation but only marginally down to a
little over 12 percent at the start of
next year it won't be back into single
digits the bank believes inflation until
the third quarter of next year so above
10
for the next nine months i think it will
have fallen back to around five percent
by the end of the year but for anyone
who is looking at this storm of impact
on their personal finances let alone
businesses trying to navigate a way
through we are looking at a picture of a
contracting economy huge inflation and
little sign of anything to offset that
and bring down the pressure on the
economy for at least a year because the
driving force of all this more than 50
percent of the impact on inflation is
energy prices wholesale energy prices
are driving this and they are largely
external international impacts that the
bank can do very little about it's
rising the increase in interest rates a
day is an attempt to try and prevent
that becoming embedded through things
like an increasing wage spiral i think
wages will go up around six percent this
year but because the labor market is
expected to remain tight when it does
the impact of the uh the contraction and
interest rates begin to hit next year
they do say employment could rise to
around five and a half percent that's
nearly two percent more at the moment so
the one one glimmer for those certainly
the job market is there is some choice
at the moment but that may change too
this is a really chastening readout from
the bank of england that will uh make
everybody sit up and take notice
well it is bleak to say the least an
economist's worst nightmare is
stagflation which is potentially
something that we're facing here in the
uk and of course all this will make a
very interesting sky news debate a
little later on because we know of
course that the economy has played
center stage hasn't it in the battle
between liz trust and rishi sunak and
we're also just hearing paul that the
bank of england monetary policy
committee of nine members they voted
eight to one in phase favor of this rise
to one point seven five percent so
pretty pretty much uh you know unanimous
uh vote from all those npc members for a
50 basis point rate hike and of course
we're going to be hearing from andrew
bailey as well the governor uh this hour
what are you expecting him to say in
terms of the outlook for the uk economy
well i'd be interested to see the
governor put it into some kind of
context we might also get a little bit
of preempting positioning from the bank
as to what may be quite a lot of blame
one wonders that might be coming the
fingers might be pointed at the at the
bank for allowing in the views of some
of its critics some of those in and
around the leadership uh debate in
election in the conservative party that
the bankers acted too slowly it didn't
act quickly enough last year to try and
tamp down inflation and now what's
happening is is too little too late the
bank has announced that it will begin
monetary tightening guilt sales later
this year technical stuff but
essentially means removing some of the
uh flow of money in the economy that
some liz trusted team particularly have
suggested has been a driver of inflation
but i would expect to see him set out uh
how he believed i'm interested to hear
him say that how given the huge external
shock to the economy that the increase
in energy prices has brought how
how this rate rise will address domestic
inflation and how it will attempt to uh
it won't slow down the economy even more
as one of the questions one might have
asked him before seeing the forecast was
are you concerned that a big rate rise
now relatively will tip the economy into
recession well he's given us the answer
in these forecasts which is that the
economy is now already heading for a
recession uh in the fir in the last
quarter of this year so that perhaps is
not a factor but be interesting to hear
how he addresses the impact on
individuals we have
people facing this huge rise in energy
prices are tripling something that's
going to push on some forecasts half of
the population into energy poverty if we
define it as spending more than 10 of
your income on energy bills this is
going to become a mainstream challenge
for the affluent not just the poor and
now on top of it those who have got
tracking mortgages mortgages that match
and follow uh the bank base rates set
here in thread needle street are facing
through no fault of their own overnight
a rise of north of 100 pounds a month
that's another increase in
the cost of living and for
right that won't affect everyone plenty
of people are on fixed rates but those
fixed rates are going to start coming up
in the next year or two and the market
expectation and the bank won't pin its
colors to that master market expectation
is that interest rates will get above
three percent over the course of the
next couple of years before
stabilizing so hearing how a man who's
responsible for the big macro picture
and steering the economy from this
building behind me how he addresses the
challenge to individuals which has just
got a little bit harder because what the
bank has done but the the rationale
behind generally behind raising interest
rates to try and
tamp down
rising inflation is that if it's not
hurting it isn't working but it is by
many people's reckoning this may be the
first time the bank has ever increased
certainly in the period of independence
since 1997 it's ever increased interest
rates
during a recession many of the
assumptions about how the economic
economy works and is managed have been
turned on their head by this session of
shocks from brexit through covert and
the disruption which was continuing
before the war began in ukraine and
they're dealing with the aftermath
behind me we'll all be dealing with the
aftermath in our personal budgets for a
very long time to come